dans cette vidéo on va essayer de
rentrer un tout petit peu dans les
détails de la théorie aux motos pic des
types
bon bien sûr comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer je vais pas réussi a résumé
un livre de 400 pages dans une vidéo de
20 minutes
tant qu'on on va voir jusqu'où on peut
aller en tout cas je vous ai mis un
sommaire de la vidéo dans les
descriptions si vous voulez sauter
certaines parties
l'idée de base de la théorie aux motos
péter type c'est d'avoir des règles de
construction
en fait ce qu'on va faire c'est on va
définir un univers dans lequel certaines
règles de construction sont valables
pour tous les types de cet univers alors
comme pour éviter le paradoxe de roczen
notamment ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on
va devoir se lisent être restreint se
limiter dans la construction possible
des types c'est à dire que par exemple
on ne va pas s'autoriser à construire
des ensembles de partie d'un ensemble
donc l'axiome des partis là ne marche
pas dans un univers eu a priori comme on
l'a vu dans l'épisode de 24 à chaque
fois qu'on a un certain type x on va
devoir aussi spécifié pour les types x
des opérateurs de construction des
éléments de xxi on va aussi devoir avoir
une espèce de recettes pour construire
des fonctions qui sortent de x on va
appeler des opérateurs d'induction il
dans notre univers ce qu'on va aussi
pouvoir faire ces combinés certains
types qui ont déjà été construits pour
former d'autres types de notre univers
donc par exemple étant donné deux types
a et b de notre univers eu on peut
construire les types à flèches vers à
droite b qui va être ensemble tu vas
être le type des fonctions de alan b
on peut aussi construire à croix b le
produit cartésien des types a et b et a
+ b
la somme disjointes 2a et 2b en
particulier chacun de ces nouveaux types
à flèche b à puce beac robes et va être
associé à des constructeurs pour ces
types et des principes d'induction donc
par exemple
regardons a + b pour à puce v n'a deux
opérateurs de construction pour
construire un élément de a + b soit on
utilise la fonction input left qui va
prendre un élément de à et construire un
élément de à puce b soit on va apprendre
la fonction du constructeur input wright
qui va prendre un élément de baies et
construire un élément de a + b et on
sait que tout objet de a + b va être
forcément construit par l'un des deux
constructeurs
donc qu'est ce qu'un élément de a + b
c'est quelque chose que l'on peut
construire via l'une de ses deux
fonctions
ensuite le principe de l'induction pour
construire des fonctions qui sortent de
a + b vient pour pouvoir construire une
telle fonction il nous faut au près
à la bhl de fonction une fonction qui va
de a dans x si on veut construire une
fonction de la plus belle rixe est une
fonction qui va de bay dans x donc si
j'appelle left la fonction de adam hicks
et dwight fonction de bay dans x alors
je vais pouvoir construire à partir de
l'est et white une nouvelle fonction
tout cas à partir de l'altérité je vais
pouvoir construire la fonction f qui va
être obtenue donc en appliquant
l'opérateur d'induction de du type a + b
appliquée donc au typique c'est le type
de sorties et aux fonctions left right
qui nous ont permis de construire f
particulier on voit que cette fonction
interdiction du type à puce b va être en
fait une fonction qui à tout type x2
l'univers eu et à toute paire de
fonctions adam hicks et b dans x associe
une fonction de a + b dans it's ok donc
ça ça me dit qu on peut construire cette
fonction est maintenant quelles sont les
valeurs de fonctions m
et bien pour connaître les valeurs il
suffit de cliquer les valeurs de
fonctions f à tous les éléments que l'on
peut construire dans x or on sait
exactement quels sont ces aliments ce
sont les inputs left appliquer un
ensemble un aimant a2a ou une poutre ait
appliqué un aimant b2b et du coup la
règle de calcul associé à l'impro
principe d'induction 2 1 + b veut nous
dire que f
appliqué à input left de havas est égal
à left a&f appliqué à une pause wright
de b va être égales par définition à
wright appliqué à b comme je l'avais dit
dans l'épisode 24
on peut aussi généralisée tout cela au
cas où le type de sortie type x ici
dépend en fait de l'input de la fonction
considérait alors des fonctions dites
dépendantes ou f2 x va pas être du même
type que f2 y du couvert voire des
notions intéressante par m6 et égaler y
met pas de poisson définitionnelle alors
2 x va être égal avec des grecs mais pas
vraiment parce qu'ils sont pas dans le
même type
du coup il va falloir transporter l 2 x
dans le type auquel appartient m 2 y
pour ensuite dire qu'ils sont idiots
égaux dans cet autre type qui est des
histoires de transpole qui rendent un
peu les choses un peu compliquées mais
toutes ces histoires de fonctions
dépendantes est en fête ipernity
notamment lorsqu'on cherche à prouver d
égalité donc pas l'ambition veut une
fonction f qui a tout élément x d'un
ensemble grand x veut associer une
preuve que x est égal à x donc là
forcément on a une fonction qui dépend
de son input double f sera en fait
plutôt une fonction qui est dans le
produit tx1 éléments de grand x que il
s'était dit à la x et où commence à
sentir le problème si x des galets y
mais pas de façon définitionnelle le
type x égal à x va pas forcément être le
même que le type y est égalé grecque
pour l'heure j'ai envie de généraliser
un petit peu cette histoire de produits
donc plus généralement lorsqu'on a des
fonctions dépendantes
le type de sortie va être un certain
type c 2 x qui dépend du petit x
appartenant à grand x de l'input et donc
c'est de x ou si peut être par exemple x
est égal à x c'est le xv a du coup être
un élément de lui un type
ça veut dire que c'est en fait est une
fonction qui a tout élément de grand x
associe un élément de l'univers un type
de l'univers nous fonction maintenant
qui va prendre n'importe quel est mon
petit x deux grands types ses aveux lui
associer un élément de ces 2 x va être
une fonction dépendantes on note f qui
appartient à aux produits sur les x
appartenant à quantix de ces 2 x et on
parle de pi type un exemple ultra
important de pi type c'est la fonction
qui va toujours donné une preuve que x
est égal à x ça ce soit appelle la
réflexivité de la réflexivité ou réfl ça
va être du coup une fonction qui
appartient aux produits pour tous les
types de l'univers du produit pour tous
les éléments de ce type tous les
éléments petit x 30 x x est égal à x
donc dans notre univers on a cette
fonction là qui nous est donné on peut
voir ça comme un axiome de la théorie
des types en ce cas un axiome qui est
s'appliquer à notre univers pu étant
donné une fonction c'est qui a tout
élément d'un type x associe à un type de
l'univers on peut aussi construire le
sigma type associés
la fonction c'est donc on note donc la
somme pour les x appartenant à x de ces
2 x donc ça va être quoi un élément de
ce type là un élément de ce type là ça
va être une paire sous la forme x y ou x
le premier élément va être l'élément de
grant x et y va être un élément de ces 2
x de façon importante donc la somme des
ces 2 x c'est un type
donc c'est à une certaine valeur de
vérité si on veut et en tout cas pour
prouver que ça il fait un théorème que
la somme des ces deux os x est encore m
on peut toujours construire un élément
de ces de la somme de 7,6
il suffit de fournir une paire de la
forme xy comme j'ai présenté plus haut
et du coup la somme à une interprétation
très naturels en termes d'existence dire
que la somme des ces 2 x est habitée
possède un aimant c'est dire qu'il
existe que l'on peut construire même un
élément petit x tel que x et y
appartiennent à la somme des 6 2 x et du
coup on peut voir y éléments de ces 2 x
comme une preuve que cédric c'est vrai
donc imaginons que ces 2 x ça soit une
formule logique quelque chose qui nous
parle de du fait que xv a fait une
certaine propriété ou non la somme des
ces 2 x revient à dire qu'il existe un x
tel que ces 2 x est vérifiée et prouvée
cela donc revient à fournir un x et y
quelques y est la preuve x vérifie ses 2
x hockey du coup en fait le produit
corresponde aux quantifie catr
universelle et la somme va correspondre
aux quantifie catr existentielle donc on
peut maintenant s'amuser à réécrire
certaines formules logique classique
dans le langage de la théorie des types
par exemple supposons que l'on a nous
sommes dans le type x une fonction somme
qui va 2 x 3 x 20 x et alors là comme
une activité de la somme s'écrit en
théorie des types comme le fait que pour
toutes xe et pour tout y
on a x plus y est égal à y +6 on à la
somme des x y est égale à la somme
degree 6 si on arrive à fournir un
élément de ce type c'est à dire si on
arrive à trouver une fonction qui peut
importe x et y fournit toujours une
preuve que x puisse y est égale des
grilles x alors n'aura la commune
ativités même façon par exemple
l'existence dans les murs d'un élément
neutre plus écrire comme la somme pour
les yeux appartenant à x du produit pour
les x appartenait x que la somme de e et
xx est égale à la somme de x et eux est
égal à x prouver l'existence d'un
élément neutre revient à exhiber une
paire e et z ou z c'est la preuve que
eux est un aimant neutre c'est-à-dire z
c'est une fonction qui a tout x associe
une preuve que somme de e et xx est égal
à x est une preuve que la somme de x est
égal à x plus généralement tous théorème
en théorie de type va être un type
éprouver le théorème revient à
construire un élément de ce type
quand vous vous disait que la théorie
des types c'est vraiment un jeu de
construction
c'est exactement ça tout tout ce qu'il
ya c'est juste essayé de construire des
objets dans certains types et je trouve
ça vraiment amusant que de se dire que
les mathématiques de la théorie des tifs
ou autrement dit les mathématiques selon
la théorie des types c'est uniquement ça
c'est tout un jeu de construction
écrire des types et essayer de trouver
des éléments de ces types
alors les logis
qui parmi vous me diront qu'il ya quand
même un truc est utile on à thématique
c'est prouvé des toits ou
d'impossibilité par exemple prouvé que
un truc est faux que vous pourrez vous
voir prendre un type oui et on pourrait
vouloir prouver que ce type est
inhabitée c'est à dire qu'il est
impossible de construire un élément de
ce type alors pour 1,28 sioniste c'est
des questions beaucoup moins importantes
souvent aussi beaucoup plus difficile
mais on peut quand même les traités
intérêts des types la théorie des types
contient tout ce que contient les
mathématiques classique on est capable
de récupérer les mathématiques classique
si on met les bons axiome arrêtés
auraient des types donc sécurité type
est capable de faire parler de négation
par exemple la négation sait quoi en
théorie des types bien il ya des types
de thons celles qui sont pas et habitait
alors qu'on peut construire le type ou
maps et 0 qui n'a aucun constructeur
donc forcément 0 évident puisqu'il n'y a
pas de constructeur on peut rien
construire dans zéro par définition en
particulier du coup si on arrive à
concevoir une fonction qui à partir d'un
type x construire un élément de 0,90 y
en a une fonction qui va 2 x 2 0 ça
voudrait dire que si jamais il s'est
habitait alors on peut construire un
élément dans zéro ça c'est absurde c'est
dire que x et faut dire que x ne peut
pas être habitée du chaos theory de type
c'est comme ça qu'on soit c'est dire
qu'il existe une telle fonction qui est
un élément x de quantix associe un
élément de du type dont on sait qu'il
n'a pas d'élément donc en théorie des
types on va définir la négation de x
comme étant le type x flèche 0 à chaque
fois il clair que ça c'est juste non x
avec le symbole classique de la logique
classique mais je trouve ça très
intéressant de juste laissé sa x fly 02
pas interpréter ça directement comme
étant la négation même si en effet ça
prouve que le fait que x soit habité
implique quelque chose d'absurde
mais si on réinterprète tout ça vraiment
en termes de logique du sony ça veut
dire que si jamais on arrivait à
approuver x10 reconstruit un élément de
x
et non hic c'est à dire construire une
fonction qui a x à ce 6 0
associer un élément de zéro alors on
pourrait contruire un élément 2 0 et à
partir du moment où on peut construire
un élément de zéro sachant qu'on peut
toujours construire une fonction qui va
de zéro dans n'importe quoi puisque il
ya aucune image à préciser on peut tout
construire à partir de zéro ça voudrait
dire que tous les types serait habité
partir du moment où on arrive à prouver
ixe et xe frais généraux on peut tout
construire en théorie des ti vct et ça
ça rend la théorie de type vachement pas
intéressante donc à partir d'éléments on
a réussi à prouver que x-files héros
d'aaron il faut prier pour que l'on
puisse jamais construire d'éléments du
type x fragile face il faut prier prier
mais il a voulu foule espérée en
particulier maintenant on peut exprimer
le tiers exclu qu est ce que le tiers
exclu rend logique intuition est en
théorie des types plus tôt eh bien le
tir excuces avait une fonction qui à
tout type x de l'univers tu as aussi une
fonction qui si je trouve prouve la
double négation d'alix c'est à dire si
j'ai une fonction qui a une fonction iq
s'impliquent 0 as aussi un élément de
zéro alors je peux construire un élément
de x une fois que l'on a écrit les tiers
exclus de cette manière il paraît
vachement moins évident ça me paraît pas
du tout évident que ça c'est vrai si on
raisonne purement interne de fonctions
tant donné une fonction qui construit un
élément de zéro à partir d'une fonction
qui construit un élément de zéro à
partir d'un élément de x6 j'ai ça est-ce
que je peux vraiment construire un
aimant 2x à chaque fois sa part fo c'est
pour ça que le tir exclu il a écrit
comme ça
en logique en théorie des types et sans
doute sous ses pas
il doit rejeter en tout cas une fois
qu'on a écrit comme ça ceci a tourné si
vous voulez vraiment faire de la logique
classique c'est toujours possible il
suffit de supposer que dans univers eu
il existe un élément de ce type
donc souvent cet élément va l'écrire l
om pour l'autre exclusive midol donc
supposer l'action du choix revient à
supposer qu'il existe un objet l om de
ce type là alors il y aura des détails a
ajouté notamment le fait que il ya peu
avoir différentes versions du lot avec
ce qu'ils me donnent par exemple on
pourrait vouloir qu'il ne s'applique
qu'à certains types donc on pourrait
avoir une condition qui nous dit que
pour toutes xe de l'univers eu 6 x
griffin certaines propriétés
donc si on a un certain ces 2 x qui est
vrai alors on a le tir avec ce que c'est
à dire on peut construire un élément de
x à partir d'une double négation
un truc qui est amusant pas forcément de
prime abord vous allez voir pourquoi
c'est que étant donné deux types a et b
et étant donné une fonction r2 à croix b
dans l'univers si pour tout obligé à on
peut construire un objet b telles que
air de ab est habitée alors on peut
construire une fonction f qui a tout
élément du type à associe un élément f2
à du type b tel que r2a et de l2 à est
toujours habitée autrement dit il existe
une fonction que je vais appeler ac qui
a tout élément du type produits pour les
adam à de la somme pour les bisons b2r
de ab associe un élément du type somme
pour les fonctions de adam b du produit
pour les adam à 2 r2 à et de f2 à ce que
vous voyez pourquoi c'est fou et
pourquoi est ce que j'ai appelé ça assez
et ouais assez pour ex'im du choix et
oui en fait l'axiome du choix est vrai
en théorie des types
non seulement il est vrai il est même
trivial alors il faut faire super
attention en fait l'axiome de choix tels
que j'ai exprimés là n'est pas
équivalent à l'action du choix critique
parce que lorsque j'utilise le symbole
sigma notamment je ne sous entend pas il
existe dans un antagonisme
je suis en tant que l'on peut construire
l'élément dont il correspond au sigma
quand on utilise symbole si demain on
sous-entend que l'on peut construire etc
speccy explicitement l'objet en question
contrairement à l'utilisation du symbole
l'inversé ceci étant dit il est possible
de se ramener au cas de la logique
classique en utilisant son appel la
troncature en gros xts oncle et que je
notais siic centre
le bar c'est un type dérivés de x tel
que si on arrive à prouver
x avec les doubles barre eh bien on ne
peut pas forcément déduire de x avec les
double barre un élément de x ou temps
m'ont dit on à x implique double barix
possible de concert une fonction qui a x
associe un aimant de double x mais on
n'a pas double barix implique x n'est
pas forcément possible de construire 1
et le monde x à partir d'un élément de
double bas.xe en utilisant un tronc
capture il est possible de réécrire
l'action du choix dans sa version plus
classique
ça correspond à la formule que voici ou
comme vous pouvez le voir il ya des
troncature par ci par là et bien cette
fois ce type là eh ben on peut pas le
prouver dans la logique intuition liste
et on ne peut pas la déduire des règles
de construction classique contrairement
à l'action du choix constructiviste
qu'on a vu plus haut ceci étant dit pour
les inconditionnels de logique classique
il est possible de rétablir l'axiome du
choix en théorie des types en supposant
que ce type là avec les tonga tueur est
habité par les membres ont rappelé à ses
actionnaires
le concept le plus dur et le plus
fascinant en théorie de type c'est très
certainement le concept d'égalité
propositionnelle formellement l'égalité
propositionnelle c'est comme avec ça va
être une fonction qui à tout type grand
x de l'univers eu et à tout perdre
éléments de x associe un type de
l'univers atypique mansi quantique c'est
un type et cie xy sont deux éléments de
ce type alors l'égalité x égale y va
être un type de l'univers et comme
toujours prouvé l'égalité dans ce cas
revient à construire un élément de ce
type alors on l'a vu le type xo y est un
constructeur trial lorsque xy sont égaux
par définition et ça revient à la
fonction réfuse transposer l'existence
dans notre univers qui dit qu'à tout
type x2 d'univers rue est à tout élément
petit x du type 30x alors je peux
construire une preuve qu' il s' est égal
à x cependant on l'a vu il est possible
que x et y soient égaux mais pas par
définition unifiée uniquement de façon
propositionnelle il est même possible
qu'il y ait plusieurs façon de prouver
la même chose et l'ajout renvoie vers
l'épisode de 25
pour en savoir plus le type de qualité
comme tout type de la théorie des types
possède aussi un principe d'induction
qui permet de construire des fonctions
qui sent bon de ce type par exemple on
peut construire une fonction qui va de x
égale y dans notre type c mais la façon
de construire de telles fonctions et
assez étriqués votre pour concevoir une
telle fonction il faut d'abord passer
par le type qui regarde toutes les
égalités 2x un élément notre élément du
type auquel petit x appartient c'est à
dire qu'on va d'abord construire une
fonction jay qui va du produit pour les
aides de x du cantique ce que x est égal
à z dans notre type c est ce qui est
vraiment amusant c'est que construire g
est incroyablement simple pour
construire j'ai bas il nous faut un
principe de l'induction
c'est à dire qu'il nous faut d'autres
objets
les autres avions dont un besoin en fait
on n'a besoin que d'un seul objet on a
uniquement besoin de préciser un élément
de crancey qui correspond au cas vous
aide est égal à x par définition et où
l'élément de xxx que l'on va considérer
et la réflexivité 2x est égal à x alors
bien sûr là je vous présente le cas
simple où ces ne dépend pas de x et
nidau y
on pourrait imaginer les cas beaucoup
plus compliqué où ses dépens de x et de
y
auquel cas il faut faire beaucoup plus
gaffe dans nos constructions mais l'idée
reste la même il suffit de résoudre le
cas vous aide est égal à x par
définition pour déduire une fonction
j'ai qui par exemple ici ired x égal à z
dans ces 2 x et hey à la z
du coup je peux construire un élément de
ces 2 x y
même lorsque x n'est pas égal à y par
définition mais uniquement de façon
propositionnelle et pour y arriver tout
ce dont j'ai besoin c'est résoudre le
cas où z est égal à x par définition et
auquel cas il nous faut construire un
élément de ces 2 x x qui correspond à
l'image de la réflexivité 2 x et x
une fois qu'on a réussi à se faire on a
une construction de g et on peut en
déduire la valeur de f en posant à fait
égal
ag2 y nom particulier pour si on veut
construire une fonction de x égale y
dans ces 2 x y et ce matin on a une
preuve peut qu' il s' est égal à y est
qu'on veut construire
vous calculez l'image de paix par cette
fonction f
eh ben on va simplement poussé f2p est
égal ag2 y appliquer ap que l'on peut
aussi noter g2 y paie pas si vous avez
vraiment suivi tout ce qui se passe ici
mais c'est super bizarre pour connaître
une valeur de ces de xy en particulier
de l'image dans ces deux xy d'une preuve
paix que x et y
tout ce dont j'ai besoin c'est de savoir
une image de la réflexivité 2x est égal
à x
lorsque je remplace y par une variable z
et que je posais dette égale à x par
définition c'est super bizarre mais
passons à une application pour essayer
d'y voir plus clair et si on veut
prouver que si il sait des galets
grecque alors y est égal à x comment est
ce qu'on fait pour prouver ça ça c'est
déjà ça paraît évident mais comment est
ce qu'on va faire pour prouver cela
notamment ce qui va nous intéresser
c'est comment est ce qu'on va faire pour
contenir la fonction est vraiment
déduire de preuve que c'était il ya des
grecs des preuves qui y est égal à x
alors souvenu pour ce faire ce qu'on a à
faire c'est d'abord construire une
fonction j'ai en fonction que j'ai qui
va correspondent aux cas on fait varier
la valeur de y
donc j'ai ça va être une fonction qui a
tout les maux z 2x associer une fonction
qui va de xxi gaz est dedans z égalé x
et pour construire cette fonction là
tout ce dont on a besoin c'est de
résoudre le cas ou z est égal à x par
définition c'est à dire lorsque z et
égaler x par définition balle la partie
de droite là qu'il faut à ce monde est
beau c devient x est égal à ips du coup
pour consulter il nous suffit de trouver
un élément de x est égal à x on en
connaît un c'est la réflexivité la
réflexivité 2x nous donne toujours une
preuve que ici tes gars là x
du coup on a réussi à construire
l'élément de droite lorsque z est égal à
x par définition ça veut dire que l'on
peut en déduire par le principe
d'induction une fonction j'ai maintenant
on en déduit valeur du la fonction af
que l'on cherchait en pesant f étayage
et de y
et ça nous donne une fonction de x égale
y nom y est égal à x sécurité
l'opérateur d'égalité est su
super bizarre mais c'est vraiment la clé
pour tout faire en fait c'est la clé
notamment pour la théorie aux motos pic
des types notamment pour manipuler des
chemins
en effet on a vu que si paix est une
preuve de x et hey allez y
alors f2p est une preuve il a quitté
gala x et on peut interpréter tous et en
termes de chemin paix est un chemin qui
va de x verts y est f2p est un chemin
qui veut y vers x alors f2p on veut pas
laisser comme ça c'est un objet
tellement important à l'inversion quand
on va lui donner un autre nombre plus
sexy plus plus standard on va l'appeler
du coupé - 1
on paie moins c'est le chemin inverse
alors de même façon qu'on a prouvé que
illégales y un pique nique ce qu'on peut
prouver l'implication x égale y croient
y et z implique x est égal à z
comment est-ce qu'on prouve sa encore
une fois on bat l'idée c'est de faire
varier les valeurs de y ait deux aides
donc on va écrire une fonction qui pour
tous l'ump va construire une fonction de
x et galut croit huet égale avait dans x
est égale avait alors comment est ce
qu'on fait ça encore une fois on va
utiliser le principe d induction de
l'égalité on va devoir l'utiliser deux
fois pour lui et pour vais donc pour eu
d'abord bas principe d'induction va
prendre le cas où x est égal à u18 égal
à x par définition ensuite pour veiller
bon va prendre le cas où bettega lui par
définition mais dans ce cas eu est égal
à v est égal à x par définition du coup
le membre de droite ce sera x est égal à
v qui devient ici à la x par définition
or un élément de ces gars-là x bassin
c'est très bien concevoir un ça va être
la réflexivité 2x est donc là encore on
voit que l'on peut construire cette
fonction à partir du principe de
l'induction de l'égalité et à partir de
l'élément réflexivité 2x qui appartient
à x est égal à x on obtient ainsi une
fonction de composition et étant donné
une preuve paix est de xda y ait une
preuve qu y est égal à z la fonction de
composition permet de construire une
preuve composition de paix
q qui va être un élément de x est égal à
z
là encore on va utiliser une autre
connotation plus passe partout on va
simplement noté ça paie point qu et ça
va être la concaténation des chemins
mieux encore on peut aller plus loin et
étudier des chemins entre des chemins
on peut si on a deux chemins dont les
pontes de départ et le point d'arrivée
sont les mêmes on peut aussi le voir si
on peut varier ce chemin pour passer
d'un chemin à l'autre sans théorie et de
motos pis c'est très classique et bien
on a la même chose en théorie des types
aux motos pic des types tôt et on en a
d'ailleurs vu un exemple dans l'épisode
25 ou vous ai parlé de la sphère s2 s rs
de est défini à l'aide d'une égalité
entre deux chemins il était
propositionnelle non trivial entre deux
boucles pourtant trial donc s2 pour
rappel c'est le type qui est obtenu en
construisant un élément de ce type va
écrire aux sauteurs base et une égalité
entre la réflexivité de la base et la
réflexivité de la place
c'est un chemin entre boucle et donc
c'est le deuxième constructeur surface
va être une boucle parce que j'ai des
points de départ et d'arrivée sur la
semaine mais c'est une boucle entre des
boucles triviale on parle d' homo topic
du second ordre plus généralement on
peut aller même plus loin dans des
dimensions et parler des groupes domoto
pis dimension de viande plus grande d'un
type x données et en cela les types de
météorites et ils vont avoir beaucoup
beaucoup plus de structures que les
ensembles de la théorie des ensembles un
dia vu que les types venez accompagnés
de constructeurs et de procédés
induction en plus de ça ils ont des
structures homo topic
c'est à dire des chemins entre
différents points et même des chemins
entre les chemins et ainsi de suite
on dit que les types vont avoir une
structure d'infini groupe aux ide est en
fait une fonction entre deux types va
devoir respecter être compatibles avec
ces structures de
l'infinie groupe aux ide en fait une
fonction va devoir être un facteur c'est
à dire qu'il va devoir transformer les
chemins en d'autres chemins et avoir pas
mal de consistance comme ça qu'ils vont
devoir être respecté et ce qui est
vraiment fou c'est que ces structures
qui sont d'ordinaire réservés aux
spécialistes de la théorie aux motos pie
où des soupes très pointue et prend en
fait ils deviennent maintenant
accessible très facilement et très
rapidement à la définition de la sphère
et du cercle qui sont très très très
sain et on peut les étudier avec une
poignée de définition et quelques lignes
de code dans un programme comme coque et
ça à cérences à la magie de la théorie
en moto pic des types
bref vous l'aurez compris je vous
recommande fortement la lecture de ce
bouquin